bom a mim coube esse tema inquietante de
qual o caminho que a morte escolhe
cromos de se conectar com que o processo
da desconexão
nesse tempo que chega para todo mundo
acho que me escolheram trata aqui por
conta do meu trabalho e um cuida de
pessoas que morrem e essas pessoas que
eu cuido elas escolheram é no revivendo
não sem doenças que ameaçam a
continuidade da vida dela são doenças
muito graves e que determinado momento o
sofrimento se faz de uma forma presente
muito intenso e ao reconhecimento da
necessidade do livro esse sofrimento
então eu digo que existem as pessoas que
não resultando em as pessoas que morrem
desistindo e as pessoas que recebem
cuidados paliativos elas morrem dizem
pelo fato de trabalhar com isso há mais
de 20 anos
eu percebo que é um grande privilégio
uma grande oportunidade
todos os dias da minha vida em observar
o que acontece com as pessoas quando
elas estão enfrentando esse tempo tão
sobrado que é o fim da liga
e aí o que eu vejo que a primeira coisa
que desconecta quando uma pessoa está
vivendo esse período onde a medicina não
tem nada para oferecer que modifique o
curso natural da doença dela não tem
cura e muitas situações não têm mais
controle
a primeira coisa que desconecta é a
atenção do médico em relação aos
cuidados da pessoa a atenção do médico e
de todos os profissionais de saúde
envolvidos que infelizmente durante toda
a sua formação e todo seu empenho para
adquirir conhecimento durante a vida
profissional de caron somente a saber
sobre doenças e essas pessoas não sabem
é cuidar da vida que quando uma pessoa
qualquer
somente em sherman até que ela morra ou
comigo e como a doença não é mais um
grande propósito de intervenção a
primeira coisa que desconecta é olhar
esse médico que cuida da sua pessoa e de
todos os profissionais de saúde que
estão envolvidos nesse processo de
cuidado as frases características desse
momento é que são ouvidas tanto pelas
famílias como pelos pacientes e e muitas
vezes até por isso as pessoas a
informação que estão acompanhando esse
processo é dizer para elas é assim mesmo
não tem nada pra fazer pra perdendo a
doença só perdendo a luta contra a
doença é perder a luta contra o câncer é
perder a luta contra a doença carioca
perder a luta perder a luta nos casos
das situações que as pessoas enfrentam
doenças neurológicas que elas não têm
mais contato com o mundo
a partir dessa evolução da doença dela é
muito comum você ouve a lombada aqui ele
não estava aqui não aqui com já foi a
segunda coisa que dê se conecta segundo
momento em que há uma desconexão quando
a morte anunciada e senti um processo é
claramente vinculado a um desfecho final
de de fim de vida ou de morte é você
entender que boa parte das coisas que
você considerava valiosa vamos toda a
sua vida não tem a menor importância
porque o que com que neste momento são
possibilidades que ao longo de toda a
nossa vida a gente deixa de lado tem um
poema do norte barros não pode causar um
grande mestre pois ele ajuda a gente
entender muitas coisas certas e erradas
que tem e aí tem a madeira que ele falou
assim eu dou respeito às coisas
desimportantes e aos seres dizem
cortante
e é nesse momento em que você vai dar
respeito às coisas que você considerou
de pouco valor ao longo de sua vida e
agora você tem que terminem e essas
coisas começam a ter um valor muito
grande você começa a se desconectar de
papéis sociais você se dê se conecta de
valores e condições que não fazem o
menor sentido de você considerar
valiosas ou importantes você decide se
conecta com aquilo que não faz você ser
feliz é muito especial esse momento
porque quando você tem a consciência da
sua morte você adquire uma
responsabilidade muito maior em relação
à sua condição de ser humano feliz nesse
mundo e o que faz a gente feliz é o que
a gente tem
o que faz a gente feliz é o que a gente
é
e quem que tá nossa volta pra ver quem a
gente é de verdade
para além da nossa doença que além das
nossas posses
nesse tempo que a gente toma consciência
da nossa morte ela está mais próxima
nós só vamos poder usufruir dessa
possibilidade de ser feliz se a gente
tiver uma condição minimamente
confortável e daí a importância de olhar
para essas pessoas que enfrentam as
doenças que a nossa continuidade da vida
dela de uma forma ampliada com a livre
desse sofrimento físico emocional social
familiar e espiritual
e aí quando você de fato começa a cuidar
de uma pessoa que tá bem no seu processo
ativo de morte
a gente começa a testemunhar um tempo
que não faculdade de medicina a gente
não aprende a conduzir a faculdade de
medicina faculdade de enfermagem da
faculdade de todas as áreas de saúde
elas não ensinam pra gente o que
acontece com as pessoas
quando elas iniciam este processo ativo
de motos onde não há o que possa ser
feito não será interrompido
a gente tem isso é muito bem escrito num
medicinal brincam a descrição que eles
trazem que a gente é sobre a dissolução
dos elementos na dissolução dos
elementos
eles consideram que não são os feitos de
terra água fogo e ar e que na hora que
eu amo que a gente vai morrer que nós
vamos morrer
nós precisamos passar pelo processo de
dissolução desses elementos o primeiro
que dissolve a terra a terra marcada
pela imobilidade dissolução da terra
marcada pela imobilidade pela
fragilidade física pela dependência
depois que passa pela dissolução da água
que é o momento onde nós vamos
permanecer em profundo silêncio interno
também não só já tinha jogado de forma
mas também internamente silenciosos onde
a gente vai mergulhar numa profundidade
muito muito muito intensa para a gente
encontrar nossa essência
e aí quando a gente encontra a nossa
essência nós começamos a dissolução do
fogo
a dissolução do fogo é como se cada uma
dessas ervas tomasse consciência de que
o tempo acabou
e aí cada uma das servas mostra o que de
melhor sabe fazer e se você pensar que
todas as células mostra o que de melhor
elas podem fazer seu pulmão vai estar
super envolvido na nesse processo de
expressão do melhor que o comando pode
ser melhor que o rio pode ser o melhor
que o coração pode ser
e aí você é melhor isso é muito é quase
mundial esse processo de identificação
da melhora que precede a morte
a visita da saúde a melhorar antes da
morte
é é muito bonito isso a pessoa melhor do
nada e ninguém entende
e geralmente quando ela está internada
ninguém entende tanto - os médicos hora
que ela melhora a funcionar já que
melhorou vão fazer tomografia melhorou
vamos fazer a ressonância vanjoki
melhorou
vamos fazer o tratamento e aí a pessoa
pode ter horas nessa dissolução do fogo
e ela vai desperdiçar em silêncio dentro
de um aparelho de ressonância ou dentro
de uma cirurgia
esse momento de a dissolução do fogo
serve para que esse ser humano que
habita em não se manifeste
e aí o melhor que você pode ser vai ser
revelado neste momento da extinção do
fogo e finalmente a gente vai ter
solução do ar
os orientais dizem que a gente recebe o
auto emprestado
esse é um sopro divino que se aproxima
de deus drama diversa natureza se chama
de quem quiser
o generoso que ofereceu esse sopro vital
para a gente e na dissolução do ar você
vai devolver seu capital porque a sua
missão na terra está com 30 mas o que
pensa que a missão terminou é muito
sagrado você olhar pra isso como algo
que é comprido é possível que a gente
através de técnicas aprendidas a gente
consiga se colocar no lugar do outro tem
uma técnica de psicologia que chama
rapport onde você começa a interagir com
outra pessoa repetir os movimentos como
faz você pode repetir a última palavra
que ela disse e depois de alguns minutos
e tem total conexão tem até uma
recomendação da sua técnica onde você
deveria sincronizar com a respiração da
pessoa
esse é um excelente exercício de empatia
durante o processo ativo de morte você
pode tentar empatizar sincronizar com
todas as soluções a imobilidade à
imprensa que seu
essa busca pela sua essência depois da
dissolução do fogo a manifestação da sua
essência toda bondade que habita o amor
que tinha bica verdade que abriga você
pode dar chance de isso tudo acontecer
apenas com a sua consciência da morte
mas de verdade você não vai conseguir o
empate usar com a dissolução do acre
e aí esse momento da morte de se conecta
a sua empatia e quando a sua empatia de
se conectar você tem três caminhos para
escolher ou você não se importa
ou você assume protagonismo do
sofrimento porque aí você acha que você
sofre mais que a pessoa que morre se seu
filho se a mãe se é o pai se você é meu
irmão seja quem você for você pode tomar
essa estranha decisão de assumir o
controle do protagonismo do sofrimento
já que você sofre mais do que todos os
envolvidos
você pode ter a terceira opção que é
opção de quem ajuda e nesse espaço você
tem um encontro maravilhoso como das
capacidades mais incríveis que a gente
tem como seres humanos que a compaixão
quando o amor encontra o sofrimento
nossa compaixão ele isso num texto de um
sábio oriental e é perfeita definição o
amor em conta o sofrimento não só com
paixão e como que a gente põe a
compaixão em prática
em primeiro lugar você reconhece que o
sofrimento existe
depois você repouso
o seu coração sobre o sofrimento você
não pega aquele sofrimento que você se
coloca no lugar da pessoa que só porque
lembra que a sua empatia técnico neco
e aí você deseja genuinamente que esse
sofrimento seja aliviado
nesse momento você se conecta com o que
você sabe com que você sente o que você
tem
e que você pode pra fazer algo para
ajudar se a pessoa tem o seu sofrimento
aliviado
e aí você faz isso
esse trajeto faz com que a gente possa
entender que a morte que desconecta e
seu presente e seu futuro quando você
morre você não começa aqui
isso não vai mais amanhã mas você se
conecta com a sua humanidade e com todo
o legado de amor que você pode deixar
nessa vida
nesse tempo que permaneceu por aqui
quando a gente tem a consciência da
nossa morte é possível que a gente possa
ter uma grande oportunidade de entender
que talvez a gente demore tempo ainda
para a gente ser aquilo que a gente quer
ser mas que nós não temos mais tempo a
perder sendo quem a gente sabe que não
vale a pena ser um campeão
é